want to know what's eating at theaters  this weekend apes must defend themselves  against an army of angry humans led by  woody harrelson in war for the Planet of  the Apes it will be a planet of apes a  gene age girl comes into possession of a  magical box that grants wishes  but extracts a gruesome price in wish  upon just soul my son bought you sold  into an unhappy marriage a young woman  is drawn into a fateful affair in Lady  Macbeth every cool to hell em high water  I'll see what's hot in theaters with  this week anticipation  so what's your weekend ticket going to  be let us know by commenting see you  next time on weekend ticket  [Music]  go to war with hunger counter your  craving to get a free movie tickets the  War of the plant of the apes from you  buy a $25 limited-edition get start it  in theaters July 14 hey Robin jump